- Hello, everyone.
Thanks for joining today's session.
For enterprises that operate
in regulated industries
like financial services,
compliance is not just important.
It's existential.
My name is Hassan Tariq.
I'm a principal solutions
architect with AWS,
and I work closely with
customers like Stripe
on their AIML initiatives,
and joining me today is Chrissy
and Christopher from Stripe
who led the development of this solution.
I'll let them introduce themselves
when they take the stage.
So here is the agenda for today.
We'll start with covering
some background context
of why agents can be a good
fit for compliance use cases,
and then go over some
background and challenges
of the actual use case that
compliance teams faced at Stripe
and then what solutions they
implemented, and, you know,
the benefits they achieved from it,
and ultimately we'll end up
by discussing what's next
and some lessons learned along the way.
So before I go into the
details or, you know,
we start talking about how
agents can be beneficial here,
let's take a look at what's at stake here.
So according to a research
study conducted by Forrester,
enterprises spend around $206
billion per year globally
on operations related to financial crimes.
With North America alone
spending around $61 billion to this total.
Now this is a very massive spend,
but it reflects the complexity
and resource intensity
of meeting regulatory requirements,
and this is not just a static number.
It's growing.
According to some compliance
teams based out of Europe,
they shared that the
compliance regulations
and the demands that they're
getting from the authorities
is increasing by up to 35% year over year.
So this means they are working
through these different cases
and have to produce a lot of documentation
and spend a lot of extra time doing that,
and that's where when
Experian conducted a survey
with these compliance
teams trying to figure out
what type of tasks they perform,
what type of documentations
they need to do,
they discovered that almost one third,
up to one third of these
tasks can be automated.
So just imagine giving back
eight to 12 hours per week
to these compliance analysts
so they can focus more
on strategic analysis and decision making,
and that's exactly where the agents
can play a big role here.
Think about the best compliance
analyst that you work with.
They are really good at
asking follow up questions
and connecting the dots among different,
various different data sources.
So if agents can do
the initial investigation
and data analysis,
these analysts can focus more
on the complex decision making,
and, you know, nuanced judgment calls.
When these agents can do the
heavy lifting of the analysis,
initial research, it frees up
a lot of the analysts' time,
and they can scale up.
They can perhaps review a lot more cases
than they are regularly doing.
It's like giving each analyst
a dedicated and tireless
research assistant.
This whole process brings
consistency to this analysis also,
which means you're insured
that every case will go through
this rigorous step process
and none of the data
sources will get missed.
And while doing all of this
whole process through agents,
when the analyst is focusing
on making the decisions,
the agents are doing the documentation
and preparing the audit
trail for those decisions.
So in short, analysts focus on the why,
whereas the agents focus
on the what and how.
So this is all great, but you
need a very solid foundation
for these agents to operate,
and we will hear shortly from Stripe team
how Bedrock provides this foundation.
So now I will pass on to Chrissy
to go over some background
and discuss about the
challenges that they faced.
- Thank you, Hassan.
How you doing?
Happy holidays and happy Cyber Monday
if you care about shopping or payments.
So before I dive into our AI use cases,
let's take a step back
and talk about Stripe as a company.
So, many people known Stripe
as a payment processor.
Last year alone, we processed
1.4 trillion in volume,
with a big letter T, and that
is 38% up year over year.
And take a guess, so
that number constitute
1.38% of the global GDP.
Wow.
So we are great in payment processing
and we bring good vibes to our developers.
These are all great.
Over the years, we are also evolving
into this comprehensive financial
infrastructure platform.
So our internet, which was
invented in the early '90s,
and it wasn't designed with a
native protocol for payments.
So Stripe build the financial
infrastructure on top of that,
and that is what's enabling
the emerging protocols
such as Agentic Commerce Protocol, ACP,
if you follow us closely
on Twitter now called X.
So our platform is very modular
and you can choose exactly what you need.
May it be global payments, moving money,
or platformization of your
money via Stripe Connect,
or automating back office
tasks like tax and billing,
we handle the heavy lifting by
integrating with local banks
across 135 plus local currencies,
and while doing all these,
we're maintaining 59s
uptime, and on average,
we're processing over 500
million requests per day
and that number might
just slightly went higher
during this BFCM.
If you are interested,
please go to bfcm.stripe.com
to look into further information.
So definitely we're solving
very interesting engineering challenges.
That is just a means to a bigger end.
So you ask what is a bigger end?
Ta-dah!
The bigger end is our north star.
Growing the GDP of the internet.
Sounds amazing, right?
So to realize this macroeconomic impact,
we realized as a company very early on
that we need the solutions to scale
with our explosive growth
without sacrificing safety and compliance,
and that, my friends, bring us
to the heart of our challenge
that we're discussing today.
So when you ask people
what is FinTech compliance,
most people will say, well,
just following the laws.
But at Stripe, our answer is
it is a foundation of trust.
It is a mechanism that
ensures that our platform...
To ensure that our platform...
Ensures our innovative technologies
follow the rules of global finance.
We view trust as a
unified responsibilities
with two critical dimensions.
One is ecosystem integrity.
We enforce this know your
customer, know your business
and the money and anti-money laundering.
This is to ensure our
platform will never become
a haven for crime.
So think about this,
if a sanctioned entity
tries to use a fake identity
to onboard to Stripe,
our compliance engine would be
able to block that instantly.
You might think it's easy,
but it is actually pretty hard in reality
because, you know, these
bad actors are smart.
They're constantly evolving as well.
And an equally important
dimension is to protect our users.
At Stripe,
users first is one of our
leading operating principles,
and that's one thing I
really love about Stripe.
I've been with Stripe
for almost five years.
So I think we really care about our users.
May it be adhering to GDPR for privacy
or UDAAP for fairness,
we ensure our users are never
exploited or compromised.
We realize that if we
don't protect the people
that rely on the system,
building a perfect system
does not have a lot of meanings.
So, to build up this
very effective defense,
there are four factors
that shaped our approach.
One, growth.
We're constantly growing into
new industries and markets.
That means onboarding
new users fast and safe
is paramount for us, and second
thing is the scale required
from a compliance perspective.
So we need to do enhanced due
diligence reviews at scale.
So short form is EDD,
and we do this so we can
manage users risk effectively.
Third, we are always
striving to reduce the time
to do these reviews to raise the bar
for our operational excellence.
The last, technology innovation.
So this is where Agentic comes in.
We want to completely transform
the manual compliance review
process and to build a solution
to make it faster, more consistent,
and infinitely more scalable.
So what is the core of
our business challenge?
Due to regulatory compliance requirement,
we need to do extensive
reviews for high risk users.
So think about this almost
as a detective, right?
So they're looking into
some suspicious, you
know, like, individuals.
They're trying to figure out
are they actually suspicious?
So as you can imagine,
this requires a lot of
the investigation time.
However, we're doing this every day.
We cannot take a long time.
So doing this in a timely
fashion is critical for us.
So to help you visualize
the manual review process
by completely done by
human a little bit better.
So I summarize there
are mainly two blockers.
One is from the manual process.
We realized a lot of
times, our expert reviewers
are acting as navigators.
They're just like going through
all these different systems
trying to gather and locate information,
instead of the analysts
that they're supposed to be.
So they're not really using their time
to making high value decisions,
and the second thing is scalability
and the jurisdiction hurdle.
So the biggest bottleneck
is the cognitive overload
when switching between
different jurisdictions.
So let me give you an example
of this contact switching.
Say, an expert analyst can move
from assessing an entity in California
where the retrieval process
is rather straightforward,
to evaluating a complex corporate entity
in UAE or Singapore.
So for each jurisdiction region,
it requires a completely different mindset
to decide what constitute as
a risk making it more fun.
So the threshold of risk is a variable.
The definition of a safe
business is not static.
One example for that is
regulatory compliance.
So for like, say for example,
ownership transparency
varies widely between high risk
and low risk jurisdictions.
So thinking about this, right?
So your expert analyst
is basically applying
this ever shifting rule sets constantly,
and this is a very
demanding and complex task.
Sometimes can even be error prone.
Just maybe a little bit like more analogy
to help you visualize this, right?
So every year I go through this
pain once during tax season.
Like, you need to go
through a lot of rules
and I am only doing it for
the federal in California.
So imagine how much pain these
reviewers are going through.
So bottom up, we are trying to maintain
the operational excellence
for regulatory compliance
by navigating through this
fragmented jurisdiction map.
Just linearly scaling up our
workforces with the complexity
is simply just not the solution.
So you might ask, what is a solution?
If this is a quiz in college,
I think you guys will
all get perfect scores
because Hassan kind of gave
the answers away already.
So to solve this,
our solution is to build an
LLM-powered AI research agent
to do autonomous investigations.
Here the agent does the
heavy lifting in three ways.
So number one, async
workflow orchestration.
This enables parallel processing
so the agent can look into
different aspect of the business
in parallel instead of
sequentially like a human would do.
Second, because we build this,
this plugs directly into the
existing compliance tooling.
So it works nicely,
fits naturally into
the compliance workflow
that our reviewers are used to.
You don't need to train
them to the new thing.
And the last bit, very exciting,
agents they never sleep,
they don't need to rest.
Think about this feeling, right?
If you have Roomba at
home, you turn a Roomba on
and you go out and hang
out with your friends
and then you would come home,
the home is already clean.
That's an amazing feeling, right?
So having an AI agent to do these analysis
before you even open the ticket
is exactly the same thing.
It'll do the investigation
and summarize the insights
before you even open the tickets.
So this is a game changer,
and now we have the AI agent to assist
and the humans to maintain
the final authority.
So before I hand over to Christopher
to do the deep dive into our solution,
I want all of you to leave this room
with at least three takeaways,
and obviously if you have more takeaways,
that's a bonus for you.
Kudos to you.
So the number one is oversight.
We use a human-centric validation.
Here, we're not trying to use AI agent
to replace the decision making.
Instead, we're using
agents to empower that
and all the expert reviewers
have configurable approval workflows.
So the agents are there to assist
and the humans makes the final call.
And the second thing is
we, like Hassan mentioned,
we keep a complete audit trail
and we record every single decision
and then rationale behind it.
This makes sure that we
will have enough data
to serve as a compliance grade evidence.
The last bit, so with all these
Agentic stuff we're doing,
we supercharge our reviews
to enable our expert analysts
to go deeper, faster with all
these pre-fetched analyses.
So with all these things, this is ensuring
that we're not just building for speed,
but we're building trustworthy,
auditable Agentic-compliant
solutions at scale.
So now with no further ado,
let me welcome Christopher to the stage
to dive deep into our solutions.
(attendees applauding)
- Thanks Chrissy.
Hey everybody, my name's Chris.
I'm a data scientist at Stripe.
I'm gonna walk you through
a little bit of the
technical implementation
and let's just kinda roll through
with what we're gonna go through.
So we'll start with kind of
back to the problem setup
of exactly what we're
kinda trying to solve,
why we're using agents, that kinda thing.
We'll jump into the agent mechanics,
kinda how it works under the hood,
we'll talk about how we
actually plug into the LM,
kind of the brain of
the agent in this case.
Next we'll talk about kind
of an interesting service
that we discovered we needed
as part of this journey.
We'll finally zoom out,
talk about the kind of
Stripe ecosystem of agents,
and then we'll get into the
business side of the journey,
the results, that kind of thing.
So, let's jump in.
So let's start with the problem.
We had this basically very,
very long manual review,
and I think the first thing
we wanted to think about doing
was just, boy, what if we
just threw an agent at it
and effectively just
automated the whole thing?
And that's kind of a nice
fairytale, but in our case,
it wasn't really gonna work.
The problem is this.
If you just took an agent and
you threw it at this workflow,
it'll probably spend a
lot of time on things
you really don't even need it to spend on.
It'll kinda rabbit hole,
and then it won't spend really any time
on things that you needed to look at.
I mean, this has regulatory
reasons for existing.
So we have things we need
to look at in many cases,
and so we realized early
on, it kinda made sense
to have rails for the agents.
And so there's a little
diagram on the slide there.
It's kinda meant to show you
that we effectively were able to decompose
this really complicated
workflow into effectively a DAG,
and the DAG is effectively these rails
that we can use for these agents.
Now we happen to use react agents.
One nice thing about this
kind of DAG deconstruction
is the tasks become
effectively bite-sized enough
to actually fit in the agent's
kind of working memory.
They do have kind of a
limited amount of, you know,
thought processing just the way we do.
I can't keep everything in in my head,
and the reason we're even using
agents in the first place,
and I think this is
important, is, you know,
why not just use like LMs
or something like that?
Well, I think the reason agents work well
is 'cause they can call tools,
and I actually think
that's the main value.
I have a very biased
perspective maybe on agents,
which I'll share a little bit later,
but I think that's why agents
are even practical here,
and we'll talk about
that a little bit more.
One interesting thing,
and this goes back to the fact that yeah,
it would've been nice to
just throw an agent at it
and have it be done, but
we actually keep humans
in the driver's seat in this case.
They're making all the decisions.
Agents are just there to
effectively inform our reviewers
to make the best possible decision.
They can use it or not.
That's up to them, but this is very much
still a human-driven workflow,
and we still found a good
way to make that work.
So who wants to see the agent?
Actually, I think I'm
getting a call right now.
What in the world?
I think he just finished a case.
What's that?
You want me to tell 'em
about Amazon Bedrock?
You know what?
I'm doing the presentation
here, all right?
All right, we'll get to it.
Agents.
All right, so we're using a react agent.
Let's talk a little
bit about what that is.
I kinda think agents think
a little bit like I might
if I have a complicated problem.
Someone might gimme a question,
we'll call it a query in this case, okay:?
Let's say it's like 10
divided by pi, okay?
I'm not gonna know that offhand.
Some of you might actually
know that, but I don't.
So I'm gonna call an
action to use a calculator
and I'm gonna wait for that calculator
to come back as my
observation, and at that point,
I'm gonna think if I now have the answer.
Yes I do, so therefore I'm gonna progress
to this final answer stage.
So really what we care about in our review
is ultimately this final answer.
That's really all we care about.
What it does in the meantime
is kind of an implementation
detail to our project,
I guess you could say.
Now, in reality, and the reason
we even use agents in this problem
is we have much more complicated queries
than something like that.
And so, look, I'm a data
scientist, so, you know,
maybe I get like analytics
ask or something like that.
I might need a few queries.
I have an idea of an
initial query I'm gonna do
that might be close to what I needed,
but maybe I see some issues,
maybe I'm gonna rerun
that query a few times,
and so you can imagine I'm looping
through this thought
action observation loop
as many times potentially as I need.
You can imagine, and this diagram
doesn't depict it all that well,
but you can imagine this could
actually loop around forever
and then it would maybe be true
AI, whatever you wanna say.
But at the end of the day,
LLMs have a finite context window
and so this effectively becomes
a bit of a challenge for us.
So in our investigation,
really the reason we're using agents
is because we need it to
rabbit hole sometimes.
Sometimes we don't.
We always need it to cover all the bases.
And so when we're
basically going deep down
in some of these rabbit holes,
these prompts can get very long.
So one thing I like about
this slide is it kinda depicts
this kind of one plus two plus three
plus four type of kind of behavior.
So I'm not like a 10-year-old gals,
but that looks kind of quadratic to me.
So effectively what that means
is that as the agent needs to dig
deeper and deeper and
deeper to answer a question,
it's effectively getting
a longer and longer prompt
that you effectively are
paying for every single time,
and it's gonna be
actually a quadratic cost
over those number of turns, I believe.
If you think about the entire cost
of your, you know, agent operation,
you're paying for input tokens,
you're paying for output tokens,
and you can kind of tell here
probably you're gonna be dominated
mostly by the input tokens in this case.
There is a solution, however, to this.
I believe that solution today
is in the form of caching,
and so why is that a solution?
Because if I don't need
to reread that prompt every single time,
it's almost as if I'm paying
for that final prompt once,
which is more of a linear
situation, which is superior,
and that's where we're
gonna get back to bedrock.
So Bedrock is our provider
that we can utilize effectively
for this kind of prompt caching,
but that's not all I'm gonna
talk about on this slide.
We do use Bedrock for our LLM provider.
We also have our own internal
Stripe services as well.
So we use this we'll call
it the LLM proxy service
for this presentation.
I think one way it really helps out a lot
I think on this project
is that we have a lot of
people using LLMs at Stripe,
and so, you know, what could
happen is, I don't know,
let's say another team's
doing some testing,
or maybe they're scaling up.
That could crowd out my bandwidth
on a potential LLM provider,
and so by centralizing this proxy service,
we can effectively solve
this noisy neighbor problem
to constrain basically those neighbors
from hogging all the
bandwidth I might need,
you know, for this project, let's say.
Now there's other benefits too.
Obviously, we have, you know, guarantees
because we're doing it ourselves
around kind of the availability
of this service, et cetera.
We can do authorization,
we can make sure the
right LLM is being used
for the right use case.
Maybe there's some LLMs we
feel like is too sensitive
to run certain data on, et cetera,
and so this allows us to kind
of funnel those use cases
to the right place.
Potentially, this service allows
us to also configure things
like, you know, model fallbacks as well
if one of the model
providers isn't, you know,
outta bandwidth or something like that.
So why is Stripe using Bedrock and why?
You know, and we're using
AWS in this situation.
I think one of the biggest
benefits I see for this project
is actually probably around
the standardization of the
privacy and the security.
So I don't know if you've like,
worked at a big company before,
maybe you wanna use this like,
new LLM provider for your project,
but then that's not gonna work
because it needs to be vetted by security,
and one really nice
thing about Amazon for us
is that we effectively
do that vetting once
to get on that platform,
and then it's effectively
standardized there.
So Bedrock provides us access
to multiple vendors of models,
and we get that kind of standardization
of that security around that.
The second point I wanna say
is more around kinda
the bells and whistles
that come along with it.
So we've talked a little bit
about the prompt caching already.
That can save you a lot of
money if you're, you know,
doing some sort of Agentic flow
where you're doing multiple
dives deeper into the data.
I also think fine tuning is
a really interesting one too,
and I know like the
vendors have been providing
really good models lately
so maybe it's kind of fell off the radar
for a lot of people,
but I see a big opportunity
for this project
mainly because the vendor model
comes with kind of unforeseen like,
deprecation schedules, let's say.
Like, let's say we wanna be focusing
on adding new questions, but oh boy,
now this new model that we, you know,
we're having great success
with is gonna get deprecated.
Well, I prefer not to have
to focus on old questions.
I wanna focus on new questions,
and so by fine tuning,
maybe I could claw back some performance.
I think the bigger thing
is just that we can now
deprecate on our own schedule,
and that seems amazing.
So I love the bells and whistles
that come along with Bedrock.
That's been very helpful.
I believe there's more as well.
The last point I'll make is
that it's really one API,
but you're getting many models
so this kinda comes back
to the standardized
privacy and security thing
where you plug into it once,
you don't have to have
that overhead of, you know,
basically in this case
setting it up, connecting it,
doing the integrations, et cetera.
Another thing I'm gonna talk about here
is when this project started,
we didn't have this service
called this agent service.
So why do we have it now?
Well, because we didn't
have it first basically.
What happened was we had
this kind of classic ML
inference system across Stripe,
and the original plan
was to basically hack in
this kind of Agentic workflow
into this kind of ML inference system
thinking it's close enough,
it's gonna get us there,
and it was shot down quickly
for very good reasons
and those reasons are mainly
that it really requires
a totally different set of
hardware among other things.
So you can imagine with
really traditional ML,
you're really compute bound.
If you think about it, you know,
let's say you're running an LM,
you're gonna need a GPU
or maybe at least one GPU.
If you're running something like XG Boost,
you might want a lot of CPUs,
but that is what you're waiting on.
You're probably getting a
pretty consistent latency
with whatever that computation is.
So you have very short
timeouts, for example.
You also have very
deterministic control flow,
the model always runs
exactly the same way,
and you're basically paying
a lot for these machines.
They're hard to set up,
you're trying to minimize
the amount of machines
you need, et cetera.
Agents are kind of the
opposite in all those aspects.
So agents, particularly if
you're using a vendor model,
you're just waiting for it to come back.
You're waiting for the
LM to respond to you,
and so you're actually not
doing a lot of compute at all.
You're just like waiting around.
You need a lot of threads,
a lot of lanes basically
to wait around for all
the different agents
that might be running on the same machine.
You can expect very long
timeouts in some case.
You can imagine like what if a tool call
needs to call a database?
Could be minutes.
I remember when we had engineers
like first spinning out this
service and they're asking me,
how long of a timeout do you need?
Like, is 30 seconds okay?
And I was like, I think we're gonna need
like, five, 10 minutes.
So very, very different
profile of compute.
Also very non-deterministic.
I mean, some answers it
might know very quickly,
it only needs one tool call.
Some may need to loop around
in that, you know, thought
action observation loop
for quite a while.
So you don't know exactly
how long it's gonna take.
Tiny machines might be
true and might be false,
but like quite honestly, you
really just need a lot of lanes
to wait for network calls.
So we'll talk a little bit
about the history of this agent service.
We will start with like,
there's almost like beginning
of Q1, which isn't in here,
which is like it didn't even exist, okay?
And we didn't even think
we necessarily needed it.
We tried to hack it into our
kind of traditional ML service.
Again, that got shot down,
but we realized it was gonna be
very impactful for this project,
and we saw that it was gonna be something
that was gonna generalize pretty well.
And so kind of miraculous,
but we got this thing
spun up in about a month
after deciding it was
really gonna be useful
and we spun that up quickly
by just making it a little monolith
with a very kind of,
let's say, primitive API
that kind of reflected
the way we were hacking it
into the ML inference system.
So you can imagine an ML inference system,
you're gonna have some sort of classic
like predict endpoint let's say.
In this case, we had
this kind of synchronous,
you're gonna have to wait for it.
If we go back to the react agent,
let's just say you're giving it the query,
and then the output is
you're just gonna wait
until it provides that final answer,
and that was enough for this project.
It wasn't tremendously
hard I think to get going,
but I think it was amazing
we got it in about a month.
So we started there in Q1.
In Q2, we started
polishing it a little bit.
So we added ways to do
evaluation for agents,
we added in tracing so
that we could, you know,
more easily debug what's
happening behind the scenes
within maybe that thought action
observation block in this case,
and we had a interesting developer
and Stripe decided to actually spin up
this like, no code agents kind of UI
where people could just
build their own agents,
add whatever tools they
wanted, and that enabled
this kind of mass proliferation
that we ended up seeing in Q3.
So Q3, interesting enough,
is where we started really
pushing the boundaries
of this project as well,
and so we started hitting
kind of the capacity limits, let's say,
of this entire project.
And so we ended up taking
what was originally
this kind of monolithic design
and then allowing every single use case
to spin up their own service.
So that solved that kind
of noisy neighbor problem
within the agent service itself.
Q4 has been a kinda
interesting development
on the functionality,
and so you can imagine
maybe this product requires
more of a ML-inspired API,
just kind of that predict on point,
but there's a lot of use
cases around just chat bots.
And chat bots you wanna be
able to interact with 'em,
you wanna be able to see
kinda their thought process,
all the different logs
of the chat, let's say,
and so this new API kind of allows
some of these kind of
stateful streamed updates.
So it really enables that,
and what's interesting is
this may be part of, you know,
kind of the no code agents approach,
but we have I believe like over
a hundred agents at Stripe.
I did a recent change.
They're all over the place.
I might rabbit hole a little bit here,
but I don't know if you actually need
like a hundred agents to be successful.
I'll say, like, from my bias perspective
of working on, you know, this project,
I will say you could probably get by
with like a shallow react agent,
maybe like a deep react
agent in some sense,
maybe like a to-do list
that can spawn sub agents,
but I would say that hundred
agents may be an artifact
of the fact that, you
know, we allow people
to really move quickly at Stripe
and there may be a lot of
prompts baked in, in my opinion,
to the agents to get to
that, to that number.
But I dunno, that's just my opinion.
All right, so let's zoom out a little bit,
talk about kind of the
full ecosystem at Stripe.
We'll start back with the reviewers.
So remember that we
talked a lot about agents,
but actually, the human
reviewer is really, you know,
the star here and they're in the loop.
They effectively interface
with this whole system
through their, you know, web UI,
the review tooling, et cetera,
and we talked about this, you know,
big DAG in the beginning.
Well, that review tooling is effectively
the orchestrator of this entire DAG flow,
and so you can imagine
that maybe before the review even begins,
we know we can kick off
a lot of these agents
to kind of front run research
for some of these questions.
But as the reviewer
progresses through the review,
you can imagine what
context may become available
to actually answer
deeper into that review,
and so you can imagine that this kind of
this review tool and application
is what determines or what
triggers effectively this agent
to begin front running
some of this research.
Now, the rest won't come
as too much of a surprise
'cause we've already kind of gone deep
on all these little
kind of pillars in here.
The react agent basically interacts
with the rest of the
ecosystem through two ways.
The first is this LLM client,
which will hit our LLM proxy
that we've talked about before.
That'll handle things like,
you know, model fallbacks,
potential of token caching,
solving that noisy neighbor problem,
those kinds of things that makes sure
that this system is actually robust.
The third is how does it
actually get the signals
that we use in our investigations?
Well, that's where the
react agent comes in.
It's able to call tools.
That could be an MCP client.
I know that's been a big thing.
Could be Python tools,
whatever works really.
Something that we do not show here
is we do have to QA this as well.
So this is a sensitive space.
Regulators need to know that, you know,
this is working soundly, and
so, you know, part of this
is keeping humans in the
driver's seat in the first place,
but the second part is like,
we have a very rigorous QA process
that's not actually
depicted here, and boy,
there's a lot of craze of having like LLMs
be judges, you know, on
many different use cases.
For this project though,
we really wanna keep,
everything needs to pass
the human quality bar
and that means we need to have humans
basically in the QA phase as well.
So I'd like to see it
become more systematic,
but it's not really
something that fits well
into this diagram here, but it does exist.
All right, so let's talk a little bit
about the whole journey here
now that we're kind of through
all the implementation stuff.
This really started as
kind of a moonshot idea
and interestingly, you
know, we spent all this time
talking about agents,
we knew agents were gonna work for this
probably in about less than a month.
You know, we set up a quick
notebook to kinda demo
how it might look on a
few particular questions.
Very impressive I think right away,
and so we knew that this
was gonna be applicable.
Quite frankly, I think that's
what it really allowed us
to kind of get the push
to actually stand up
this new Agentic service
which was really necessary
to actually make this happen.
So we took, you know, we went
from this small notebook demo,
fail fast if you will, but it succeeded,
and eventually are getting to
this full enterprise system.
Totally, you know, their own
services stood up, et cetera.
Really was miraculous.
We also did this by having
humans completely in the loop,
not just during the review again,
but also during this kind of
really rigorous QA process
to make sure that, you know,
the agent's not hallucinating, let's say,
or is providing sensible answers,
or can be dependent on enough.
And we were able to finally
get our initial questions out
by the end of the half.
Sorry about that.
So let's look at another timeline here.
We started with those
notebook scripts in early Q1.
That allowed us to know that
this would actually work
and was worth really investing
in as a full on product.
We bootstrapped that agent service
very quickly with that monolith.
Just the bare minimum
of kind of what we needed to get going,
and we took it as far as
we could and it did well.
Hooked that up with all the
enterprise LMs, et cetera.
By Q2 we finally got that first
question in, which was huge.
And I wanna say, you know, a lot of it
was really actually
working with the ops team
to understand exactly how
they were really gonna get
the best use of this as well.
So that's a big component of this.
It's not just the agent, unfortunately.
I wish it was that easy,
but really getting in
it to the bar of quality
where you know a human reviewer
is actually gonna depend on it.
Let's say it's like
helpful 20% of the time.
They will never look at it
and then you're just
spending money on LLMs
and getting absolutely nothing out of it.
Maybe even 80% you could
get that kind of reaction,
and so it took a while for
us to kind of work with QA,
make sure this was done on rails.
We didn't want them just, you know,
like going to a deep
research-like interface
asking anything they wanted
because you don't know
what it's even good at answering, right?
So that was actually a big part of Q2.
So we got that first question out.
Q3 we started really
trying to scale it up.
So we started launching
a lot more questions,
looking into things like
caching or, you know,
now we care about costs,
and Q4 is where we've really already got
a lot of the easier questions,
maybe even a lot of the questions
like before the review even
starts that we can get.
But now if we're gonna
continue making gains,
we need to actually be able to
use context within the review
to kind of build upon what we have,
and so that DAG orchestration
makes this a little more
complicated and that's, you know,
something we can really
plug it into in Q4.
So we're really
just scratching the
surface with this honestly.
So what did we get for it?
Well, one nice thing we have is we do have
a little telemetry from the reviewer
so they can tell us if
it's helpful or not,
and what we're seeing
is they're finding it
about 96% helpful.
So remember I talked a little bit before
about people need to trust
this system to use it.
So like, if this thing's
good, I don't know,
30% of the time, 40% of the time,
maybe even up to 80% of
the time in my opinion,
they'll just learn that
they are not gonna get
any use of it.
They'll do all the research themselves
and you're saving no time,
you spun up this very complicated system,
and so like getting
this kind of quality bar
was a challenging process,
and it took a lot of kind of
human reviewer involvement,
talking to the control owners,
getting a sense of like,
what even human reviewers
struggle with, you know,
when they're running these reviews
and trying to build around that.
So there's a lot of prompt iterations
you can imagine to get there.
Another thing is that we, you know,
I've talked about this a few times,
but we managed to keep
human reviewers in the loop.
You know, outcomes of these reviews,
they carry weight and
so you wanna make sure
that it's made in a sound way.
Keeping a human in control
of these at all times
is I think a really good
way to move along here,
and doing this in a way
where we can show a regulator
exactly what the agent has
found, how it found it,
what tool calls it decided to make,
what the result of those tool calls were.
So we have complete auditability
across, you know, anything
the agent touches here,
which is helpful.
But all of this really
comes to this number,
which is that ultimately, we
were able to make this review
wildly more efficient.
So we measure the
performance of the review
is kind of like average handling time.
How long does this thing take?
So with just these initial questions
that we're kind of front
running the research on,
a human reviewer can spend
26% less time on average
on these reviews as a result.
So again, agents are not doing the work,
they're not making the decisions,
they're not automating really anything,
but they're still able to see
these massive efficiencies,
and that is gonna allow Stripe
to keep up with user growth,
maybe changes in
requirements for the review
as regulations change, et cetera.
So that's been massive.
So what are we gonna do next?
Well, we're working right now
on kind of expanding that orchestration.
We wanna get deeper into
this very complicated review.
Another thing is, I don't know
how far we're gonna get with this,
but I would love for like
the kind of evaluations
of how well the system is working
to be a little bit more streamlined.
I definitely think LLM judges
per se could be a good way
to like fail really bad
models really quickly.
I still suspect you wanna have
humans kind of in the loop
in order to determine if it's
really good enough to ship.
The 26% reduction is massive,
but it's just scratching the surface.
Again, as we get deeper into this review,
we can imagine this is
gonna get a lot bigger.
And fine tuning is really exciting.
I don't know if we're
gonna get improved quality
with fine tuning.
I definitely think we're
just gonna have more control
of what we wanna spend our time on
and not be surprised by
deprecation schedules, et cetera.
RL is a fascinating one too
mainly because the answers
here are verifiable
and so you can imagine
like this end-to-end
kind of training loop where
you're actually learning
like a superior brain to the agent
that could maybe have less
tool calls in the future
which saves context, et cetera.
So that's a really interesting area too.
All right, so what did
we learn as part of this?
Probably the first lesson we learned
is really just like splitting
these very complicated reviews
into these more bite-sized tasks
that can really fit well into memory,
that are very easy to judge
if it's consistently good or bad.
Remember, we have humans
doing kind of the evaluations
of if it's good enough.
So keeping the tasks small enough
is kind of part of the
fight to kind of get there.
The bite-sized task
was absolutely critical
to make really any progress here
to be anything more than a demo,
and those bite-sized tasks allow us
to do this kind of orchestration.
So it allows us to actually
start building upon context
that's actually gonna come
up inside of that review
to be able to go deeper and,
you know, to get to a point
where we're getting more
than just 26% reduction.
Another thing was, yeah,
infrastructure has been a big help.
Certainly we could not have done this
probably without the agent service we had.
It just was not gonna be hacked into.
This ML inference system
it would've been a complete
abuse of resources,
and so definitely, you know,
don't be afraid of doing that.
So what do I want you
to take away from this?
I would say don't try to like,
automate everything right away.
I think that's like a natural instinct.
Everyone thinks agents
are just gonna like,
completely replace everything
everywhere tomorrow
and that's just not how it's gonna work.
It's great to keep humans
in the driver's seat.
You should use these things as tools.
They may not be actually even good enough
to completely automate it.
Who knows?
I mean, the only way you're gonna find out
is to have a tractable way
to incrementally attack
some of these very long complex problems
into these kind of bite-sized
tasks in my opinion.
You know, agents are great
and they're really amazing
when you have almost an
infinite amount of like,
signals you could be
baking into your answer
and you don't even know
which ones to be looking at.
Really the tool calling
is I think what makes the
agents useful maybe generally,
but definitely for this project.
You still need rails for
'em though because again,
you don't want an agent that's
just spending all of its time
on something you don't
even care about that much
and not spending any time on the things
you need to care about,
and so that's why I think
those rails are kind of critical
to this kind of like incremental approach
to those efficiencies.
And the last thing is,
yeah, do not be afraid
to build new infrastructure.
Particularly for agents,
Stripe's seen a lot of success.
You know, we have so many agents.
You can imagine
just how much we're using
this now across Stripe.
It doesn't have to take
that long to build either.
Like, we had something in a month,
and you could too if
you don't have it yet.
Maybe you do.
So that's all I have for you today.
(attendees applauding)
- So I hope this was a good
learning session for all of you
and you'll be able to take
some of these learnings
and implement in your own organizations.
So we'll wrap up this session.
Stripe team will be here to
answer any of your questions
that have been left unanswered,
and one final thought is
Chrissy initially mentioned
about the Stripes Agentic
Commerce Protocol, ACP.
If anyone of you are interested
in learning more about it,
there is a session.
I think it's on Wednesday around 2:30.
So you can look that up and come there
and meet some of the other Stripe folks
who have been working on this protocol,
and in the end, please make sure
to give feedback in the app.
That's how we improve.
Thank you very much.